foreign
happy to be here and I want to talk a
bit about how people experience and uh
respond to being victims of
discrimination
we live in a world in which People's
race or ethnicity affects the kinds of
outcomes that we receive
it's also the case that the kinds of
outcomes we receive depends upon our
gender
whether or not we are gay or straight
various kinds of physical mobility
issues whether we have a physical
disability whether we're particularly
short stature whether what weight
category we belong to all of these uh
influence the outcomes that we receive
likewise our age matters to the outcomes
that we receive
so while we may be against theoretically
discrimination
it is an outcome or a form of social
experience that many people uh
experience it's a kind of stressor in
life
and despite our principled objections to
the Discrimination that people
experience
many of us might believe that people
clay are a little bit overly ready to
claim discrimination as a cause of their
negative outcomes
that in effect We Believe
widely that people who are victims of
discrimination are just
um playing the victim card that they are
attempting to avoid responsibility for
their negative outcomes and uh instead
are avoiding responsibility
why is it that this is unlikely to be
the case first of all we know that there
are social costs
whenever a member of a disadvantaged
group claims to be experiencing
discrimination Advantage group members
often attempt to explain that away as
due to anything except discrimination
so uh it's not just that Advantage group
members
um dislike to hear claims of
discrimination it's also the case that
disadvantaged group members are well
aware of the credibility problem that
they have
and so our own research has revealed
that disadvantaged group members fear
when one of their own claims to be a
victim of discrimination they fear that
they will be made to look
um badly uh that they will be made to
look like whiners and complainers so
they too often negatively evaluate
members of their own group who who
report discrimination
so the point here is that nobody
advantaged or disadvantaged is very
happy hearing about discrimination
claims
so we have lots of reasons here to
believe that there are social costs but
what I want to emphasize today are the
psychological costs of experiencing and
complaining about discrimination
what are the consequences the
psychological consequences of perceiving
yourself as a victim of discrimination
well first of all experiencing
discrimination is a form of exclusion
it's saying you are not allowed you are
not permitted
you uh secondly experiencing
discrimination is a kind of devaluation
in the broader society that you aren't
uh respected and valued both of those
are conditions of poor psychological
well-being we know that for people to
thrive they need to feel included and
valued and respected
in addition we would expect that
perceived discrimination will have
negative consequences for psychological
well-being precisely because it
undermines any sense of control it
communicates that you are powerless to
control and obtain positive outcomes
desired outcomes that they aren't under
your control
so for those reasons we would certainly
expect that perceived discrimination and
the more you perceive it as pervasive uh
the more harm it will do to
psychological well-being
to address this these claims what we did
was a giant meta-analysis that is where
we quantitatively assess the huge
literature that has addressed this
question over the years
it involves more than 144 000 people of
many different groups disadvantaged and
advantaged groups and overall what we
find is that there is a negative effect
of perceived discrimination on all sorts
of measures of psychological well-being
everything from measures of depression
to measures of Life satisfaction and
self-esteem feelings of control and so
on and the next question is though for
whom is perceived discrimination uh
particularly harmful does it matter does
it differ for different kinds of groups
well the first question is uh whether or
not it matters for members of
historically disadvantaged groups what
you see here is that the effect of
perceived discrimination in
disadvantaged groups on well-being is
reliably more negative that is worse
than it is for advantaged groups
but we might want to look at different
uh look at what kinds of disadvantaged
groups have been studied
what you can see is that there are many
faces of discrimination you can
experience discrimination based upon
your gender race uh sexuality and so
forth what you see here is that the
effects of perceived discrimination are
weakest for uh discrimination based on
sexism and racism those are groups that
have had civil rights movements and
attempted to create a collective
identity and struggled against
discrimination whereas for the other
groups that are the relationship is
significantly stronger and more negative
particularly the the most negative is
for those with a physical disability
now most of the studies in the
literature that have looked at the uh
these different faces of discrimination
have especially uh examined the effects
for racism or different forms of uh
ethnic groups
so we uh wanted to look at what are the
consequences for different ethnic groups
so just looking at those studies first
of all the one thing we find and the
only time in which perceived
discrimination is unrelated to
psychological well-being is for white
participants
this is a group for whom uh
discrimination is not very pervasive
however for all the other ethnic groups
uh we see that the more you perceive
pervasive discrimination uh the worst
psychological well-being is it's
particularly and significantly worse for
groups that have not had any any kind of
successful Collective movements to bring
about change that is for Arab Muslims
Asians uh and other immigrant groups
so you've been turned down you didn't
get that job you didn't get that
promotion you've been refused uh being
able to participate in desirable
activities because you have a physical
disability you've been denied a an
apartment
um in a desirable neighborhood uh and so
forth you these are all objective
experiences of discrimination that
people may have
but what we want to understand and what
researchers in the work I've showed you
so far have looked at is people's
perceived discrimination so uh our
perceptions and the objective events
that we experience may not be the same
thing so just to take a silly example
when I was a little girl growing up in
St John New Brunswick it was the time of
the big American space program and we
all watched on television as Neil
Armstrong walked on the moon and I was
so thrilled I remember telling my dad at
dinner that I want to be an astronaut
when I grow up and he told me girls
can't be astronauts that but you could
be if you want to fly you could be an
airline stewardess
now I thought okay that's that's good
um you know flying to the Moon flying to
Saskatoon no big difference it's okay I
can do that the point here is I had
objectively been told about things that
I would be excluded from by my gender
but I didn't perceive it as
discrimination I thought airline
stewardess was pretty good idea
okay so what we want to understand is
what's the distinction between
objectively experiencing Encounters of
discrimination and uh people's
subjective interpretation of their
experience so for that we need
experiments we need experiments in which
we deliver to people The Identical
objective event and then we want to know
what's the consequences of perceiving it
as discrimination or as perceiving it as
due to something else
so there are two uh there's fewer
experiments but there's still a
substantial number of them in the
literature that have done exactly that
they come in two different varieties one
variety of experiments
um are of the sort that
uh the experimenter always delivers to
people a very negative outcome and then
induces some people to believe it's due
to their group membership so for example
um I don't get some nice outcome I'm
giving negative feedback and I'm induced
to believe it's because they're
prejudiced against women or I I still
don't get that negative outcome and so
on or I'm induced to believe I didn't
get that negative outcome because I
don't have the ability and skills so I
didn't get that positive outcome
okay uh what you see here and this is a
very good test of this self-protection
idea what you see in all of these
experiments is we see no significant
difference in concluding that my outcome
is due to discrimination or My outcome
is due to uh I didn't deserve that good
outcome
so there's no self this is very good
evidence that there's no self-protection
to be had in claiming discrimination
there's a next set of uh both of them
are pretty uh unpleasant conclusions to
arrive at
the next set of experiments are very
different they too deliver a negative
outcome to people but they vary uh
something more broadly were told uh in
one case that discrimination against
women for example is pervasive uh it's
everywhere uh or it's we learn that
discrimination against women is a pretty
rare thing it doesn't really happen very
much anymore it's isolated
so here what we see is truly negative
causal effects of perceiving yourself as
a victim of discrimination that's
pervasive across context so if you
believe these outcomes reflect broader
devaluation of your group
the same outcome when it's interpreted
is due to discrimination produces
negative harm to psychological
well-being
okay well how then if people experience
discrimination and continue to
experience it how do we successfully
cope with it
we know that there's a negative
consequences for well-being of
perceiving pervasive discrimination
but we also know from a variety a whole
host of studies that have looked at
different disadvantaged groups that to
the extent that they form a positive
minority identity this helps to
alleviate those negative consequences of
perceiving discrimination
so what can organizations do to help
people who
encounter discrimination
pervasively across context if we know
that Minority identity is so important
one organization that we've worked with
I'll just take an example is Little
People of America
this is a group of people who have a
genetic
disorder that produces very short
stature and there are people who
experience very severe discrimination in
the marketplace and in public spaces and
so forth
what we've found is that this
organization
is able to help people partly because
people with many forms of members of
disadvantaged groups are geographically
dispersed and
um are unable to
see that there are others who share
their condition and that it's a valuable
it's okay to be disabled as long as one
can take pride in that identity so
little people of America have been very
successful in helping their members to
improve their psychological well-being
by encouraging a positive uh disabled
and proud minority identity
so I just want to leave you with and
return to the the point I started with
in a sense the myth that many of us may
hold that uh perceiving discrimination
is an easy easy thing to do it's an easy
way out it's a way of explaining and
avoiding responsibility for our uh poor
outcomes
that we saw here no evidence that
supports this at all that in fact
claiming discrimination is a very
difficult uh thing to do there are
social and psychological costs
associated with doing so and to the
extent that we can honestly and help
minority group members who are
experiencing the Discrimination uh to uh
take pride in their uh identity
we will go a long way to celebrating
diversity Among Us thank you